Freezing Water in Unbreakable Containers
Some listeners may recall a science class
in which an excitable teacher walked to the
front of the class to show off a small, cracked
steel container, seemingly damaged by an incredibly
powerful, but tiny force; only for said teacher
to reveal that the damage had been done by
nothing more than water.
However, what would happen if you put the
water in a container it couldn’t break out
of and then froze it?
The short answer is that the water still turns
into ice; however, if it genuinely cannot
break the bonds of the container it is trapped
inside, it turns into a very different kind
of ice than we’re used to seeing.
We currently know of 15 different “solid
phases” of water, aka ice, with each type
being distinct due to differing density and
internal structure.
The form you’re likely most familiar with
is Hexagonal Ice which is what happens when
water freezes normally under regular conditions.
If you keep lowering the temperature of Hexagonal
ice, it eventually becomes Cubic Ice; tweak
the temperature and pressure further and you
can create Ice II, Ice III all the way up
to Ice XV.
Due to the inherent difficulty of producing
such high/low pressures and temperatures,
it has taken science up until as recently
as 2009 to fully document every known form
of ice.
The majority of ice’s final forms were discovered
in part by a group of researchers in the Chemistry
department of Oxford University who were able
to create Ice XII, XIV and XV for the first
time.
In the case of Ice XV, creating it involved
taking Ice VI and slamming the temperature
down to -143 degrees Celsius before exposing
it to pressure 10,000 times greater than the
Earth’s own atmosphere.
This final form of ice, and by extension form
of water, still managed to surprise even the
minds at Oxford when against all of their
expectations, it proved to be totally antiferroelectric,
being unable to hold a charge at all.
But in the simplest sense, the different forms
of ice are created through a varying combination
of both pressure and temperature, the exact
combinations of which can be found out by
taking a quick look at the phase diagram of
water linked to in the show notes.
However, scientists can artificially tip the
scales in their favour through various means.
For example, when creating Ice XIII and XIV,
Dr Christoph Salzmann and his team at Oxford
used careful measures of hydrochloric acid
to alter the temperature needed to create
the ice.
If the above seems rather simple in the scheme
of things, that’s because it was and other
scientists, such as Professor John Finney
(who was part of the team that discovered
and created Ice XII in 1996) noted as much
when questioned about it, commenting that
Salzmann’s team had done in a few years
what other researchers couldn’t do in 40.
Back to the question at hand, regular ice,
or at least the version you were familiar
with before we told you about the other 14
kinds, is capable of applying massive amounts
of force when it freezes and expands.
This is due to a very unique trait of water,
mainly that it is less dense as a solid than
as a liquid.
This density disparity is due to how the molecules
of water react upon freezing; water molecules
join together in a rigid hexagonal structure
which leaves a small, but nonetheless significant
gap between the atoms that wasn’t there
when the water was liquid.
For the curious, water reaches its densest
point at 4 degrees Celsius; any cooler or
hotter and it begins to expand.
So exactly how much force is the ice capable
of exerting?
Well, people have been trying to work this
out for a long time.
In 1784 and 1785, one Major Edward Williams
took advantage of the weather in Quebec and
repeatedly tried and failed to find a method
of containing ice.
Williams at first tried to seal water inside
of artillery shells, the cast iron plugs of
which were launched 475 feet at an astonishing
20 feet per second when the pressure become
too great.
Unperturbed, Williams then took to anchoring
the plugs in place using hooks, only for the
shells to split in two.
In another experiment, an attempt was made
to fill cannons made of one inch thick cast
iron with water only for them too to split
when it was frozen.
Academics in Florence later tried to fill
a ball made of one inch thick brass with water
only for that too to crack when it was frozen.
They later worked out that the force required
to do so clocked in at around 27,720 pounds.
For a more exact answer, you need to once
again go back to the water phase diagram linked
in the show notes, which shows that ice will
turn into Ice II when the pressure reaches
300 Mega Pascals, which is exactly, 43,511.31
pounds of force per square inch.
In other words, that’s the amount of pressure
a container would need to be able to survive
to stop water turning into regular ice, instead
causing it to turn into Ice II.
So, to answer the initial question, if you
froze water inside a container so strong it
couldn’t turn into ice, it would still turn
into ice, just a slightly different type of
ice in terms of scientific classification
and its internal structure.